breaking news now in a rescue operation
in wales has saved a man who was trapped
in a cave for two days this guy's becky
johnson witnessed that rescue and joins
us now so becky what is the latest and
uh what's the mood
there well i mean just
such a sense of elation among these
rescuers it's taken around 60 hours to
get the man out and you can probably
just see here the mountain rescue truck
uh just leaving the scene in front of it
an ambulance with that injured caver on
board
heading to hospital to get the treatment
that he's needed since he fell
sometime around saturday lunchtime and
has been trapped in this vast cave
network that's under our feet here in
the brecon beacons now yeah it was in
the last
few minutes that he was pulled out from
the cave
we witnessed that there were around 70
rescuers underground
there to pull him out there was an
orange tarpaulin put up just to protect
him as he was taken out he was carried
straight into an ambulance at the top a
bit of applause from the rescue workers
who were up there
battling the elements to bring this man
to safety and as i say a mood of huge
elation that he is out safely we knew
that he had
multiple injuries we were told after
before that he had been unable to move
but we are told that his injuries aren't
life-threatening
he has i understand been chatting to his
rescuers but he does need to get to
hospital
as quickly as possible so that's what's
happening now let me bring in peter
francis from south wales caving club uh
peter this caving network uh ogofin and
d it's it's one of the longest in
britain it's certainly the deepest in
britain and you think this is the
longest rescue mission that's been in a
cave in britain we think it is the
longest yeah in a continual carry we
have had people trapped by flood water
for a few days but to actually carry
somebody in a stretcher this is a
60-hour job it's unbelievable and it's
involved
most of the cave rescue teams in britain
and the way they work together mesh
together i just feel so proud of all of
them
and i mean the mood here is really quite
emotional i think apart from anything
else people are exhausted after such you
look incredibly emotional
it's emotional times
what do you know about the condition of
this man he's in good condition i mean i
was here when the call out started and
i was very worried then would we get him
out alive or would he deteriorate um and
all saturday we worried most of
yesterday were worried so this is a huge
really for us
you know i think it's one of the reasons
we do it
yeah
and not at all peter it's emotional
times and i know everybody's very tired
as well and i mean this man i know his
family don't want us to give away very
many details about him we know he's in
his mid 40s an experienced caver
experienced and i know he was known to
quite a few of you he was just
incredibly unlucky he would physically
he put his foot in the wrong place at
the wrong time
and he could have done it on pavement in
which case he'd been in hospital ten
minutes afterwards
but he was a mile to underground in an
awkward place all the odds were against
him but his determined his mental powers
probably got him through because he had
to be incredibly using an awful lot of
pain to begin with we know that until we
could get the drugs to him uh he stood
by all that um
all these teams i mean i'm i'm
absolutely i'm impressed to no end how
the teams work together and the whole
thing about caving is a sport it's not
competitive it's a team thing and all
these people didn't compete with each
other they worked together some of them
never a lot of them didn't know each
other never worked together before and
the fact that they pulled this off
this is oh yeah i'm absolutely thrilled
and peter we can't underestimate the
conditions that these guys and girls
have been working under there's flowing
water and stretches this cave very very
narrow stretches vertical drops in
places it's very tricky to get somebody
on a trap
the only good thing is that the water
levels didn't come up if we'd had heavy
rain it would have flooded and filled we
couldn't pick the rail would have been
impossible that didn't happen and that
really aided us so
everything was you know it worked out
for us here
okay and he's now on his way to hospital
to get the treatment that he needs
absolutely yeah fabulous thank you so
yeah if you just have a little look over
here you can see uh the teams here just
uh having a bit of a debrief uh one or
two of them mentioned that there might
be some beers i think they've certainly
earned them
over the last two and a half days here
working
24 hours a day to get this man out
safely